bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
café politique les élus locaux se
succèdent ici au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux et je reçois
aujourd'hui pour ce deuxième numéro à
l'arrachage bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
maire communiste de la verrière la
verrière petite commune de 6000
habitants élus pour la première fois par
les habitants justement c'est en mars
dernier avec plus presque 60% des
suffrages on va parler des dossiers
importants pour votre commune au
paravant pas à parler de votre parcours
et de l'actualité politique aussi
puisque l'actualité politique dans les
yvelines c'était la venue d'un ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy qui était en meeting à vélizy
c'était l'une des seules étapes
francilienne dans le cadre de sa
campagne pour reprendre la tête de l'ump
ça vous inspire quoi en tant que
responsable politique ce retour d'un
ancien président et qui plus est de
nicolas sarkozy je suis un petit peu
désespéré de voir le climat politique
actuel est de voir effectivement ce que
l'on annonce comme un retour d'un homme
qui a changé et qui revient avec les
mêmes recettes avec les mêmes attitudes
qui revient en plus avec des casseroles
qui font beaucoup de bruit derrière lui
et qui ne va pas aider ça va pas aider à
ce que les citoyens se remobilise
refasse confiance dans la politique il
ya besoin de neuf qui a besoin de
nouveaux il ya besoin d'idées de projets
il ya besoin de proximité nicolas
sarkozy a très loin de tout ça il a été
en échec il est encore en échec et on
verra bien et une deuxième chose qui me
m'interroge c'est que nous sommes en
2014 nous avons élu le président de la
république il y a deux ans et nous
sommes déjà dans la préparation des
prochaines élections
présidentielles il ya un vrai problème
d'institutions ces institutions ne
fonctionnent pas on peut pas être en
campagne permanente pour élire le
président de la république cette
présidentialisation mais est
insupportable et finalement et le tout
le contraire de la démocratie
actuellement officiellement il est en
campagne pour la tête de l'ump mais bien
évidemment ce fait ces meetings on se
projette plus sûre sur 2017 vos
convictions de gauche vos convictions
communistes sont nés à quel moment à
quel moment vous a dit je vais m'engager
de cette manière là et vers sète ce
parti-là
difficile à moi je suis un enfant de
banlieue je suis comme ça je me définis
g j'ai passé toute mon enfance à
sarcelles donc dans les milieux de
gauche forcément à la grande époque de
la gauche des idées de la gauche et donc
de gauche je suis quasiment depuis que
j'ai la capacité de réfléchir et de
penser je suis un je me suis engagé très
tôt à 14 ans j'étais déjà un militant
politique plutôt l'extrême gauche
d'ailleurs et puis j'ai rejoint le parti
communiste en 1985 donc il ya presque
trente ans
voilà parce que c'est ma famille
naturelle je suis un petit peu un petit
peu particulier je ne suis pas un homme
de parti je ne fréquente pas les cercles
des militants et autres je suis plutôt
j'ai envie de mon indépendance aussi de
garder mais si vous avez une sensibilité
mais oui j'aime bien être ce que je suis
votre première vraiment engagement
politique c'était contre la guerre du
vietnam oui c'est bien ça oui oui
c'était dans les années 50 donc vous
avez grandi avec vous avez 57 ans et on
peut quand même leur préciser et c'est
vers 16 18 ans un peu plus tard plutôt
même puisque c'était dans les années
66 73 à nos jeunes très jeunes que j'ai
commencé à me sensibilise et puis
effectivement vers la fin de la guerre
du vietnam ces 1970 1971
ces images un peu terrible je me
souviens toujours de la télévision cette
image de la petite fille brûlée par les
bombes au napalm et donc et puis
derrière tous les événements le biafra
la guerre du biafra donc effectivement
les grandes causes de la paix et du
développement dans le monde vont
toujours sensibilisés m'ont amené à la
politique reprend peut-être le fil
chronologique l'évolution de votre
parcours en politique 87 vous avez
trentaine d'années vous vous installer à
la verrière qu'est ce qui a motivé cette
installation c'était déjà dans le but
ensuite d'accéder à la mairie où il
commençait à prendre contact avec le
maire de l'époque pierre c'est la drôme
est emblématique de cette ville pas du
tout je travaillais dans le milieu de
l'animation à mantes et puis
le programme politique rodez policier de
carrière politique je suis pas moi je ne
suis pas contrairement à beaucoup qui
commet jeunes dans la carrière politique
et qui n'ont que ça en tête c'est pas du
tout ça moi j'étais un professionnel de
la jeunesse on n'est venu me chercher
pour travailler à la verrière j ai
travaillé on m'y a fait confiance on m'a
confié des responsabilités
progressivement et j'ai toujours dit je
dois beaucoup à cette ville qui m'a
permis d'avoir un parcours professionnel
tout à fait satisfaisant et donc je me
suis impliqué et la vie associative la
vie politique et puis ma foi la
complicité avec pierre sennes un cours
m'amener très vite à être son adjoint
puis à lui succéder en 2012 6 en 2012
qui vous passe la main donc c'est pour
ça que je disais tout à l'heure que le
premier scrutin dans les électeurs ses
terres en mars dernier à quel moment il
a choisi de vous faire confiance comment
c'est venu dans la conversation avec
pierre celle en cours mais qui est en
poste depuis plus d'une trentaine
d'années qui décide de partir il se dit
pourquoi pas à linge agile on parle avec
vous il a déjà des idées très arrêtées
je pense que pierre seul un cours est un
homme militant il s'est beaucoup investi
dans sa vie il a toujours voulu que
cette ville
préserve cette couleur politique et donc
il a cherché dans son environnement
celui ou celle qui aurait pu lui donner
ses gages là on a beaucoup travaillé
ensemble j'étais son premier adjoint et
donc forcément un moment donné la
question s'est posée parce que c'était
une volonté pour lui de réussir la
passation et ce qui n'est pas toujours
simple donc effectivement il m'en a
parlé assez rapidement et comme je
n'avais pas forcément de l'ylang
militaireles et rapide donc que les
choses se sont fait tranquillement au
fil du temps et quand il a été près les
parties et comme j'étais là et
disponible je suis venu au début de
votre réponse vous avez évoqué la
couleur politique c'est important de
garder la couleur politique dans la
commune aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi
être communiste justement être
communiste c'est je pense que c'est ce
ne plus éloignées
des idées de justice sociale des idées
de développement pour l'humain c'est
c'est finalement revenir à ses valeurs
fondamentales qui nous manque tant qu'il
me manque tant celle de la place de
l'homme la place de la démocratie
effectivement la participation la
citoyenneté et puis la place du rapport
aux éléments fondamentaux de la vie
c'est à dire le travail
l'amitié la construction commune de
l'avenir et donc ce sont des valeurs
c'est un système de valeurs après
derrière il y à des partis des
organisations on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord sur la totalité mais je
crois que l'esprit effectivement de
vouloir une société meilleure une
société plus juste
reste d'actualité c'est pas idéal mais
non mais non c'est pas ça peut
s'appliquer ça peut se traduire le
concret bien sûr bien sûr on va voir
comment vous vous efforcez à l'appliquer
dans votre commune dans un instant juste
peut-être une réaction vous vous
souvenez peut-être de ses déclarations
c'est en 2012 françois hollande qui est
pas encore président assez cette
déclaration aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
communistes il le dit en angleterre
et ça vous a peut-être interpeller
choqué vous avez pensé quoi à l'époque
aujourd'hui il ya plus de communistes
n'ayez pas peur c'est ce qu'il a dit en
angleterre et qu'il le dise à la place
où il est aujourd'hui on voit bien que
ça finalement ça correspondait assez
bien à cette tentation et et à l'esprit
dans lequel il est effectivement très
social démocrate je pense qu'il l'a il
faut se dire aussi que l'organisation
communiste est en recul c'est vrai le
parti communiste n'est plus ce qu'il a
été mais je pense aussi qu'il y a un
potentiel chez beaucoup d'habitants de
se regrouper je pense que ça dépassera
le cadre du parti communiste moi
personnellement je prône pour un nouveau
rassemblement à la gauche du parti
socialiste réunissant tous ceux qui ont
envie de travailler un autre modèle de
société et un autre modèle économique
parce que je crois vraiment un autre
modèle économique possible qui dépasse
d'ailleurs le capitalisme sans doute et
le socialisme aussi vous êtes dans la
lignée de jean luc mélenchon qui a
représenté globalement le parti
communiste pendant un temps puisque bien
sûr communiste s'est rangé derrière le
front de gauche ça pas fait l'unanimité
avec tous les militants communistes
d'ailleurs cette incarnation par jean
luc mélenchon vous êtes plutôt dans sa
logique se mettrait en retrait
j'apprécie les idées qu'il défend je
suis moins ces petits faux personnage je
pense que moi je suis pour un monde de
deux débats de confrontation et des bas
mais de respect je pense que je
comprenais qu'il ait fait peur peut-être
aussi parfois certains dans sa façon
d'être oui je pense qu'il faut
effectivement c'est quand on siffle a
rassemblé à réunir donc faut travailler
aussi la forme on va parler de votre
commune à présent juste le temps pour
nous à déplacer de quelques mètres dans
ce bistrot du théâtre
seconde partie de ce café politique
toujours avec l'arrachage le maire de la
verrière ce sont comme d'habitude les
habitants qui vont témoigner un petit
peu des plus et des moins c'est la
question que nous sommes allés leur
poser je vous laisse écouter ce
micro-trottoir lloris et les transports
le week end parce que il n'ya pas
quasiment pas de bus votre nom est
plutôt la ville a laissé 1 passe c'est
tranquille ce que mon petit coin pour le
centre commercial en deçà sauver un
petit peu parce que là ça s'est renfermé
un petit peu une bonne petite ville
tranquille
pas très propre quand même oui si centre
commercial c'est pas très sûr
non sinon tout tout est bien moi ça fait
quinze ans que j'habite là je regrette
pas le soir on entend les voitures qui
crament les jeunes qui hurle
en 20 ans c'est devenu de pire en pire
j'aime bien parce que c'est assez
convivial dans l'ensemble les gens se
connaissent se parlent donc voilà plus
de maisons de quartier plus de d'endroit
pour que les jeunes puissent justement
se distraire de manière positive j'ai
tout de suite précisé que ces micro
trottoir a été réalisée sur plusieurs
endroits de la ville ce qui explique
peut-être le grand écart entre les gens
qui s'y sentent très bien dans cette
ville puis des gens qui s'y sentent
peut-être un petit peu moins bien c'est
quelle est votre première réaction parce
que vous avez entendu entre ont entendu
parler par exemple des voitures qui
brûlent ça ça peut faire peur oui il ya
une personne qui va être une personne
qui est une personne qui l'a dit les
voitures qui brûlent tous les jours non
il ya qu'il y ait des skis et ressort
c'est effectivement le travail que nous
avons engagé qu'il faut poursuivre sur
le centre commercial d'orly par
puisqu'en l'occurrence c'est le lieu où
il ya effectivement des difficultés 1 2
vie quotidienne de propreté d'entretien
donc sur lequel nous intervenons
régulièrement et sur lequel nous allons
renforcer nos interventions sur le rush
comme plutôt satisfait de voir que
l'appréciation des verriers roi est
assez positif sur leur qualité de vie à
la verrière scarlets de l'occupation des
jeunes aussi dans le micro trottoir il
faut plus d'activités il faut s'occuper
de ces jeunes oui c'est ce qu'on fait au
jeune âge aussi oui le problème c'est
pas de s'occuper des jeunes bien sûr il
ya plein d'activités de dispositifs qui
existent le problème c'est le décrochage
que un certain nombre de jeunes cons
avec les dispositifs existants il faut
sans doute qu'on réinterroge nos formes
d'intervention auprès des jeunes pour
que ceux qui sont le plus éloignés on
puisse les rattraper il ya des jeunes
qui vont plus au lycée et des jeunes qui
vont pas au collège il ya des jeunes qui
ne trouvent pas d'emploi il ya des
jeunes qui n'ont plus confiance en eux
mêmes d'abord parce que c'est vraiment
déjà une crise du jeune et donc il faut
évidemment essayer d'inventer des
nouvelles réponses pour que ces jeunes
retrouvent confiance en eux et retrouve
conscience le confiance dans leur avenir
pour la suite de cette émission c'est
votre opposant politique au conseil
municipal nicolas dainville qui vous
interpellent ils à trois questions à
vous poser on va commencer par un
premier point cela porte sur la sécurité
fias juste l'europe quel étonnement jour
monsieur hadjadj la question concerne
l'absence de sécurité à la verrière des
camions intermarché ont été incendiés
des voitures ont brûlé pendant l'été une
femme s'est fait sauvagement agressé au
centre commercial il ya également un
certain nombre de verrières wac ont peur
de sortir de chez eux à cause de bandes
qui font du trafic de drogue au pied de
leurs immeubles notamment à orly parc
donc première question avez vous
conscience de ce problème et que faites
vous pour y apporter des solutions
concrètes au delà des caméras de vidéo
protection qui devrait voir le jour dans
quelques semaines trafic de drogue de
drogue violence parce que vous avez
conscience des problèmes et vos réponses
évidemment qu'on a conscience des
problèmes monsieur dainville je crois
travail à la mairie d'elancourt et il
sait conseiller j'imagine le maire
d'elancourt sur les difficultés de ses
côtés gaël en cours puisque on a le même
taux d'insécurité délinquance à la
verrière cas elle encourt donc les
problématiques d'insécurité sont assez
général dans notre région et dans notre
pays et donc bien évidemment que j'ai
conscience qu'à la verrière il y à des
situations sur lequel il faut intervenir
nous le faisons je le redis il ya une
description à ce apocalyptique on a
l'habitude avec monsieur dainville c'est
son fond de commerce ceci dit sur le
centre commercial dans les parcs au delà
de la vidéoprotection faut savoir comme
que cet été nous avons mis des agents de
sécurité de proximité qui ont donc
jusqu'à 3 4 heures du matin assure une
présence régulière nous avons aussi en
continu tous les jours une présence
humaine sur le centre commercial pour
réguler ces phénomènes nous travaillons
en coordination avec la police pour
qu'il y ait effectivement un travail sur
les trafics parce qu'il ya plusieurs
niveaux dans l'insécurité il ya les
trafics et ça c'est répréhensible il
faut vraiment que la police puisse
démanteler les trafiquants et puis il y
adeux l'errance donc des phénomènes
d'errance qui sont pas que des jeunes
d'ailleurs il ya aussi des adultes qui
sont en errance et là c'est du
traitement quelquefois psy
l'accompagnement social moore profond
sur ces personnes qui ne vont pas bien
et donc qu'il faut traiter les problèmes
dans leur diversité il n'y a pas une
seule réponse il ya des réponses qu'il
faut cumuler est ce c'est ce sur quoi
nous nous attachons en même temps tout
cela représente des dépenses importantes
et donc il faut pouvoir mobiliser les
moyens nécessaires pour pouvoir
renforcer ses disponibles justement ses
quartiers dans les parcs qui a été
mentionné c'est un quartier qui doit
quitter le dispositif des zones
géographiques prioritaires comme espoir
qu'on va réussir à ces zones qui
reçoivent des aides de l'état et vous
avez lancé une pétition parce qu'avec le
nouveau mode de calcul certaines parties
de la ville vont quitter ce dispositif
avait donc on a occupé d'ailleurs le
centre commercial pendant trois jours la
vendredi samedi et dimanche pour attirer
l'attention des pouvoirs publics on les
a rencontrés donc nous nous souhaitons
que ce quartier reste parce
qu'effectivement on le voit bien il a
besoin encore d'être accompagné la ville
a besoin d'être aidée pour pouvoir
maintenir ces dispositifs ce
désengagement de l'état vous le percevez
au quotidien c'est un problème ponctuel
sur les zones géographiques prioritaires
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique on a
eu une baisse
dix pour cent de notre dotation de
l'état l'année dernière on nous annonce
une nouvelle baisse de 10% qui s'ajoute
aux 5 % en 2013 au total de la dotation
de l'état aura baissé de près de 25% en
trois ans nous aurons perdu quasiment
trois cent mille euros trois cent mille
euros ces 10 agents communaux pour vous
donner une idée donc c'est dramatique on
est et en même temps il ya des charges
nouvelles on a pris en charge la réforme
des rythmes scolaires en partie qui nous
coûte il ya sans arrêt des transferts de
charges vers la collectivité et quand
les dotations baisse elles baissent
aussi pour l'agglomération pour le
département et donc le département et
l'agglomération nous disent oui mais
nous on va être obligé de baisser vos
dotation commun comment vous compenser
on compense par un travail très fin sur
l'organisation des services donc on
essaye effectivement d'optimiser nos
services
d'améliorer l'efficacité de nos services
par la forme et reçoit une augmentation
pour les fonctionnaires en place assez
fade embauche donc effectivement pas
dans l embauche en tout cas c'est sur
ces mêmes quelquefois regarder comment
on peut faire mieux ou tout cas la même
chose avec moins de deux salariés c'est
des économies de fonctionnement sur tous
les postes nous sommes obligés de
rentrer dans une étude de vraiment au
poste près à la dépense prête et en même
temps en essayant de préserver la
qualité des services parce que nos
habitants vraiment besoin de mon service
on voit tous les jours ils viennent nous
voir pour de l'emploi pour de l'aide
sociale pour les d'éducative et on ne
peut pas leur répondre leur faire la
seule réponse les subventions baissent
les dotations baisse on peut pas
répondre dans votre imaginatif pis
battre c'est ce qu'on a fait on s'est
battu autre question elle porte sur le
quartier du bois de l'étang à présent ma
deuxième question concerne le bois de
l'étang un collectif de verrerie roy
s'est créé pour dénoncer des conditions
de vie qui se sont dégradées des
ascenseurs souvent en panne ce qui est
inacceptable et insupportable pour eux
ce qui est également très dangereux et
puis également des revalorisations de
charges d'eau qui déstabilisent leur
budget que faites vous pour améliorer la
relation avec deux maxis que faites vous
pour répondre à ce collectif de verrerie
roy qui s'est créée qui attend des
mesures fortes de la part du bailleur
mais également de la municipalité là
c'est le bailleur qui est muet
oui monsieur david met à jour ses
connaissances puisque les choses ont
effectivement évolué depuis cet été nous
sommes intervenus fortement avec le
collectif auprès de maxis il ya eu de
nombreuses réunions et rencontres nous
avons appuyé la démarche du collectif un
prêt de deux maxis et depuis les choses
ont bougé les habitants que j'ai
rencontrés la semaine dernière nous ont
confirmé des interventions nombreux sur
les ascenseurs sur le chauffage sur
l'eau chaude donc on sent que le
bailleur a bougé sous la pression des
locataires et d'ailleurs j'ai été le
premier à dire aux locataires il me le
répète souvent d'ailleurs en disant vous
nous avez toujours demandé de nous
organiser de bouger vous pouviez pas
tout faire seul ben voilà on l'a fait on
s'est mis en collectif et maintenant on
agit donc on accompagne ce mouvement et
c'est vrai qu'il ya des résultats c'est
comme tout à l'heure pour la ville quand
on se bat on obtient des choses dont ils
en ont fait la démonstration
il reste des problèmes importants c'est
un quartier compliquée dans sa gestion
les bâtiments sont anciens maintenant
difficile à entretenir les situations
sociales sont contexte aussi donc il
faut être attentif et vigilant la
qualité du travail partenarial avec le
bailleur et avec les collectifs
difficultés sociales manque de moyens
vous l'avait déjà souligné ces derniers
mois avec une lettre ouverte au
gouvernement une tribune aussi dans la
presse et dans cette tribune vous
écriviez que le quotidien d'un maire
d'une petite ville populaire de banlieue
c'était d'agir sans cesse pour éviter
fractionnement et mia léman pour ne pas
opposer les uns aux autres oui oui ça
c'est vraiment ce que l'évolution que
j'ai pu constater ces derniers temps
c'est le fractionnement de notre société
ja je le dis souvent il ya ceux qui ont
du travail ceux qui en ont pas il ya
ceux qui ont la foi et ceux qui ne l'ont
pas il ya ceux qui qui ont l'argent qui
ceux qui ne l'ont pas il ya ceux qui
relate qui font qu'ils font pas notre
société temis émietté et au bois de
l'étang et à la verrière c'est la même
chose on retrouve ces et il ya une
tendance aujourd'hui à faire que ces
groupes s'opposent alors que évidemment
il devrait pouvoir se réunir et agir
ensemble donc notre rôle à nous c'est de
dépasser ces clivages et de faire que le
vivre ensemble devienne une réalité dans
nos mais encore une confiance du citoyen
envers les politiques parce que la scène
politique aussi qu'ils parlent même si
vous y mettez de bonnes intentions mais
est-ce qu'on vous fait confiance pour ça
est-ce qu on y croit encore c'est
difficile je pense que c'est le combat
quotidien ça j'espère que oui en tout
cas je veux y croire je veux croire que
moi j'ai pas d'enjeu personnel dans
cette affaire donc je ne suis pas
carriériste que j'ai pas d'ambition je
fais partie d'un parti qui ne vise pas
la députation ne vise pas d'être
sénateur donc voilà je suis très libre
de tout cela et donc je peux me
consacrer entièrement à la gestion de ma
ville et pas mes ambitions personnelles
donc ça me je pense que ça crée un
rapport particulier d'autre part je les
connais bien les perrières war pour y
est depuis trente ans donc ça aussi
c'est important moi je dis je leur ai
toujours dit je ne fais pas de promesses
je prend des engagements et donc les
engagements c'est d'agir ensemble pour
obtenir un certain nombre de réussites
de résultats et les promesses d'hier à
toi je te trouve un travail à toi je te
trouve un logement j'ai jamais fait ça
je ne suis pas clientéliste on me le
reproche parfois mais je ne suis pas
clientéliste il faut mettre des règles
il faut être dans une relation de
respect avec les citoyens je pense que
je les respecte j'essaye en tout cas
d'être dans la relation de respect avec
eux donc pas de promesses désengagement
un combat quotidien et puis on dit quand
on ça marche on leur dit quand ça marche
pas on leur explique pourquoi ça veut
dire qu'en milieu de mandat on peut
imaginer une réunion avec la population
que vous fassiez un bilan de ce qui a
été fait ce qui reste à faire aussi pour
voir si ça marche ça marche pas on va
faire ça plus souvent mais vu et qui
m'ont plutôt deux fois par an de faire
des points d'étape avec les habitants et
de mettre en place le conseil des
citoyens donc il y à tout un ensemble
d'initiatives qui vont être prises pour
remettre le citoyen au coeur et pas
comme un discours politicien mais comme
un discours politique je crois vraiment
à une démocratie plus responsabilisant
vis-à-vis des citoyens je crois au droit
d'interpellation des citoyens je crois
aux droits de révocation des citoyens je
pense qu'on n'est pas là pour accomplir
400 mandat pour faire plaisir on est là
pour réussir si on réussit pas bien faut
laisser la place c'est un discours
peut-être un petit peu différent par
rapport à ce qui se faisait avant la
verrière mère est restée pendant de
nombreux mandats vous voyez faire le
même parcours que bien ces lingots non
non pour plein de raisons mais c'était
une époque indifférente
aujourd'hui c'est une autre un autre
temps politique je suis aussi différent
j'ai un métier j'ai un emploi donc j'ai
pas tout à fait les mêmes positions et
puis je crois qu'il faut savoir laisser
la place je n'ai pas du tout l'intention
de faire 4 5 on n'a même pas 3 même pas
3 2 peut-être peut-être c'est un peu tôt
encore pour y penser une dernière
question de votre opposant politique au
conseil municipal la troisième question
concerne les bécanes on a beaucoup parlé
du projet des réunions ont eu lieu avec
des cabinets de conseil avec des verres
hyérois sauf que les verts hyérois
maintenant ils attendent du concret
quand est ce qu ont lieu les travaux
pour combien de logements qu'il y aura
accès donc c'est des questions très
concrètes sur un projet qui dure et je
lave ou qui commence à s'impatienter un
petit peu les verriers roi puisque ça
fait des années qu'on en parle donc on a
envie de voir le projet son
aboutissement et surtout de savoir
concrètement quand est ce que le projet
va démarrer les années même des dizaines
d'années pour le quartier des bécanes
pour quelques clés le quartier étaient
les terrains étaient bloquées pour une
éventuelle extension de l'autoroute a12
finalement vous récupérer ces terrains
parler de développement aujourd'hui on
en est où alors d'abord ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça pour un projet de cette
ampleur que nous y travaillons puisque
l'équipe de maîtrise d'oeuvre a été
nommé il ya un peu plus d'un an
et donc ça prend du temps effectivement
pour construire un projet d'aménagement
pour
maîtriser le foncier et pour rechercher
les financements tout le monde s'accorde
à dire d'ailleurs que c'est un des
projets qui va le plus vite sur le
territoire au point qu'aujourd'hui il
est porté par l'ensemble des partenaires
j'ai encore du pire bédié il n'y a pas
très longtemps qui m'a confirmé son
soutien au président roger conseil
valaisan tendance est générale on a revu
la région de même le préfet de région la
secrétaire d'état à la ville a bien
roddick le carrefour de la madone était
une des priorités donc on a fait un
chemin considérable on partait de rien
on partait d'aucun financement un
terrain vide rien et aujourd'hui nous
avons un projet nous avons des
financements acquis et nous commençons à
travailler sur la création de la zac
donc dès la fin de l'année avant
décembre une réunion publique aura lieu
pour présenter le projet
travaillé par les urbanistes donc où on
verra effectivement un projet qui mixe
l'habitat qui va vers l'activité
économique qui propose des services
nouveaux qui propose des commerces et
qui propose un cadre de vie harmonieux
puisqu'on a essayé de traiter le paysage
tout en mettant de la ville et tout en
essayant effectivement de rendre
accessible l'ensemble de ces habitations
aux verriers roi mais aussi aux salariés
des entreprises qui sont sur la verrière
mais aussi d'autres gens de la ville
nouvelle et d'ailleurs qui ont envie de
venir habiter près d'une gare une des
principales de 55 donc on a un beau
projet je pense qu'on va le partager
avec les verriers roi pendant la
campagne électorale monsieur dans une
vidéo love on veut pas de ce projet
maintenant il impatient tant mieux il a
progressé donc c'est très bien on va
pouvoir se mettre autour de la table et
on va pouvoir avec les verriers roi
travailler sur notre projet il est
important ce quartier pour le
développement de cette ville de 6000
habitants on le rappelle justement au
sein de l'intercommunalité qui devient
toujours de plus en plus bande
importante on parle même d'une
intercommunalité à huit cent mille
habitants dans quelques temps vous
l'imaginez comment la ville de la
verrière avec vos 6000 8000 10000
peut-être habitants maximum et au milieu
d'une énorme intercommunalités moi je
fais le pari que notre commune restera
un lieu d'exercice de la citoyenneté
réelle c'est-à-dire de proximité un
maire connu des élus connu paquin merde
j'ai mis en place un système qui est
assez unique dans le secteur puisque mes
23 conseillers la majorité avec une
délégation et donc les 23 travail et je
les réunis tous les mois les 23 il te
les 23 son boulot proche de la
population font des propositions c'est
aussi un élément de la citoyenneté
démocratie active donc la verrière je
suis sûr sera figure de proue d'une
ville qui saura se développer maîtriser
son développement le faire de manière
humaine réinstaller une vraie
citoyenneté au centre et puis avoir une
harmonie à l'intérieur d'une
agglomération qui sera sans doute plus
grande sans être écrasé par
l'agglomération on essayera on essaiera
de faire entendre notre différence et
une autre voie moi je prends un monde où
les différences font de la richesse
qu'est la verrière est différent une
dernière question pour terminer à cette
émission comme comme à chaque fois si
vous ne deviez retenir qu'un seul
engagement j'espère vous entendrez plus
1 d'ici la fin du mandat mais s'il en
avait qu'un seul vous deviez prendre
aujourd'hui d'ici la fin du mandat ce
serait lequel
oh la la et si vous n'achetez plus à
coeur c'est difficile parce qu'il ya
tellement de choses que je voudrais
faire que vous me posez une question
piège là franchement composer ce qui est
du plaisir
mais ça peut pas être naïf j'aimerais
vraiment vraiment vraiment que les
verrières roi que je connais depuis
longtemps qu'ils sont grandes
difficultés qui attendent emploi ou
logement puisse trouver des réponses ci
sur les la fin du mandat grâce à notre
projet de développement qu'on peut
permettre un certain nombre d'entre eux
et ceux qui sont plus en difficulté
trouver du boulot à la verrière ou
ailleurs est d'avoir une réponse en
mouvement et puis bien vivre ensemble
franchement je serai le meilleur le plus
heureux du monde parce que c'est ce
qu'on l'on souhaite on souhaite vraiment
des habitants qui s'en sortent et puis
c'est vrai que mon grand rêve c'est les
habitants qui continuent d'interpeller
qui sont pas contents qu'ils me le dit
qu'ils viennent aux réunions qui nous
bouscule ça ne gêne pas d'être bousculé
et c'est pas confortable mais on cherche
pas le confort quand on est élu merci à
la rage d'avoir participé à ce café
politique café politique qui revient le
2 novembre prochain invité jean michel
fourgous le maire ump d'elancourt
également premier vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'économie